market stalls and shops now hugged the
sides of the bagram army base
the concrete blast barriers shielding
and now deserted airfield
once the centre of u.s operations in
afghanistan
the airfield's now been handed over to
the afghan security forces
without ceremony and without any
official announcement
afghan soldiers have been busy mending a
breach in the perimeter
after looters got inside most nato
forces have quietly left this week
months ahead of the american president's
promise they'd be gone by september the
11th
after two decades
it's in stark contrast to the public
demonstration of force by the us-led
coalition which invaded the country in
2001.
the coalition toppled the taliban regime
which was sheltering osama bin laden
after the 9 11 attacks
promising to bring democracy and
security to the country
but after trillions of dollars spent on
the war thousands of soldiers and
civilian lives lost
the country is still as insecure as ever
we've been given exceptional access to
the afghan special forces
the commandos they're now
spearheading the fight against extremism
remnants of isis are now embedded with
the taliban fighters they'll face
and these are the soldiers who'll be at
the sharp end of routing them out
they're just training but soon these
commanders will be facing taliban
extremists
for real for the first time in nearly
two decades it'll be without
international support the rest of the
country
the world will be watching to see how
they get on
they're armed with american supplied
weaponry and ammunition
the training base was set up by their
american and british partners
but even these elite forces have
suffered some terrible
losses in the lead-up to the
international troop pull-out
hours before the background base was
vacated the taliban was posting videos
on twitter
claiming hundreds of afghan soldiers
have been handing in their weapons
and surrendering to them dozens of
districts have fallen under taliban
control in the weeks after the u.s
administration
said its troops were leaving the country
and before the conclusion of peace
negotiations
now there's growing anxiety about what
that will mean amid fears it'll see a
return to the extremist rule which saw
women flogged
girls banned from school and public
executions
the hasty military exit has alarmed
those who worked with the international
troops
and who now fear being targeted by an
empowered taliban who see
them as colluding with the enemy
he says when u.s forces withdrawal from
afghanistan
the taliban will come and they will kill
us
yeah my feeling is very bad security is
tense in the country with u.s
intelligence warning weeks ago that the
afghan government could fall within
months of the international troops
departing alex crawford sky news kabul